well I suppose that he is slick and that
he is a a lizard person but but
everything every single we then
continued on the DeSantis Nome debate
and uh Bill thought that Gavin won and
obviously James Carbell he's a Democrat
you know consultant so of course he said
that Gavin won and clearly I was not
going to sit there for that slicks good
yeah GL slick you know what they said
the same thing about Bill Clinton the
guy you got elected any one two you know
let me tell you something the United
States of babies you have to be a little
slick because they can't take the
truth now what was your
take I know you love well I suppose that
he is slick and that he is a lizard
person but but everything every single
what does that mean well lizards are are
slippery but every single thing that he
said was a lie everything he said I mean
this place California and come on bill
this place did you see the homeless
encampment right outside this studio
right outside the studio I actually
brought some fenel if you I talk about I
got I talk about California's problems a
lot which is probably why go Governor
Nome has not been on the show in six
years yeah so I don't pull my punches on
that I understand that oh no I'm not
saying you pull your punches but but the
fact is every number that Hannity pulled
out there whether it's homelessness
whether it's the amount of people that
left California to move to Florida
whether it's what's going on with all
the woke stuff that I know you do care
about and all the rest of it Florida is
flourishing this place is falling apart
so I think I made my case I think I did
it effectively I've still got some of
that fenel left if any of you guys want
it let me know but there quite literally
was a homeless encampment on the street
on Beverly Boulevard where the uh what
is it the CBS Studios where they shoot
this thing are from and Bill knows that
now what was also interesting about that
was that bill was like I've been very
critical so he hasn't been on my show in
six years well you're also Bill very
critical of DeSantis and Des santis
showed up and chatted with you so what
is it about Gavin Nome that will not
allow him to show up and talk to a guy
who's been critical of him who he also
says he's supporting he's saying that he
will vote for Gavin Nome if he is the
nominee